American housewife the show is all about
keeping a positive body image so that is
sometimes hard to do but so important
and that comes naturally to Katy our
Liana Aguilera found out Katie loves the
skin she's in and I'm going to be the
second that is Tao swiping Westport you
guys use the term fat on the show a lot
but it's are you hoping to like maybe
change the connotation of that word
through the show well I tell you honey
it's not it's not concentrated on you
know what I'm talking about that said
premise that she's self-deprecating
she's feeling like terrible about
herself and that's what the struggle is
I think is being trying to be fearless
and handle it there's nothing wrong
through your beautiful and amazing and
came another woman around here fatter
than me oh my god the show is about a
curvy mom who moves with her family to
an upscale town filled with super skinny
women the show originally was titled the
second fattest housewives in Westport
are you happy with the fact that they
changed it to American housewife a short
I love it in a sense of it everybody can
relate everybody deals men women kids
everybody deals with insecurities
that's humanity for six seasons on Mike
& Molly
Katie played Melissa McCarthy's sister I
don't know what I would've done without
you probably still be at that hair salon
throes of that beautician I ended my
komali we wrapped it was on the I think
January 29th and I walked in February
4th into that room of American housewife
it's just the biggest gift in the world
I could not be more grateful you feel
different hmm different how looking for
a new bag of flour
it's my Spanx like many the 35 year old
has been a variety of different dress
sizes but whatever her weight she's okay
with it did you ever feel pressure in
Hollywood because you're a woman that
you needed to be skinny no matter what
size it
I've gotten been bigger and been smaller
um but it's just been I've never I've
never had a problem with that basically
I've never let the media dictate my
identity ever
you